well more now from uganda where the
election commission
says that yuri mussoveni has extended
his 35-year rule having been declared
the winner
of the country's election well sky's
africa correspondent
john sparks joins us now on the phone
there was a lot of
violence and unrest wasn't there john in
the run-up to this
election a sixth term for the incumbent
but the opposition
claiming vote rigging
yes they are hi sam uh if you can hear a
lot of noise in the background that is
a whole bunch of president museveni
supporters on
motorcycles uh roaring up and down the
roads in
in kampala but you know this the
territory here
in kampala that the big cities with
large populations of younger people
they went for bobby wine his main
opponents real name robert chuggilani
and his
national unity uh platform a lot of uh
deeply unhappy people in the city they
think the election has
been rigged and certainly bobby wine had
a lot of difficulties getting out
campaigning he was
harassed by the by members of the
military the riot police he was arrested
on multiple
occasions the authorities said that they
were working to prevent the spread of
the coronavirus but bobby wines people
said they were just simply not letting
them get out
and uh campaign and there are also
concerns about the electoral commission
itself in uganda which is effectively
under president museveni's
control he appoints the the chairman of
the electoral commission
but uh bobby wine has done well he has
garnered about 3.5 million votes to yuri
museveni's
5.2 million votes he has done well and
more than 20 of the 70s cabinet
ministers have
lost their constituencies they have been
thrown out by voters
so that is a message that is a strong
message that
voters in uganda particularly younger
voters are tiring
of yuri museveni's rule he's been in
power since 1986.
there is a message there that is being
sent
but president museveni uh is is safe he
will as you say get a sixth term
in uganda but difficult time ahead
though for bobby wine
john says his home has been surrounded
by soldiers and he did say yesterday
that he feared for his life
that's right and we understand that he
and his wife are in
their home alone we've just seen up
there we've just been to see it it's
basically being
surrounded by a huge military
presence there's no way to get in there
he's he's
essentially voiceless now he cannot
speak he says his
phones have been cut off and that is
really an extraordinary thing to happen
to a presidential candidate who's
fired up the electorate in this country
and again won about 3.5 million
votes he is essentially under a form of
house arrest at the moment
i don't know how long that will last for
i don't know whether the authorities
plan to introduce charges
but i think the situation at the moment
is very worrying for
for bobby white